俺の名前は天才小学生屋根助。今日は街に待ったあの日。スイッチ
2の発売日だ。うわ、欲しいな。
こいつは最強の母親子ゲームにすごく厳しい。
5万円絶対買わせないわ。
お母さんス嫌です。何でも言うこと聞くから。なんでも言ったわね。
うん。次のテストで
200点取ってきなさい。
分かった。あ、バカね。
点はボりって伝っき。えほ、えほ、えほ、えほ。
それじゃあ始め
先生東案用紙が足りないのでもっとたくさんもらってもいいですか?
はあ。
てことでテストを返却。す、お前はどんだけ長い回答を作ってんぜ。端こゲームに
100点超えて200点。
はい。200点。
こんなん似てたわ。それじゃあシャトルラで世界記録出してきなさい。よい
[音楽]
ワ。
ま、こんなもんでいっか。ブ記録
2番ご。
はい。
世界新記録信じられるか?それじゃあゴムゴムの身を取ってきなさい。
[音楽]
ありたかけろをかき集め
探し物探し。
ルフィゴムゴムのみちょうだい。
お前誰だ?
お肉あげるからいいよ。うう。
はい。ありがとう。
き肉だぜひ俺にもくれよ。
ちょっとみんな喧嘩しないで。
うるせえ。フルクせよ。
はい。ゴムゴムのみ。あん楽しくなってきた。うひゃひゃひゃひゃひゃひや。ただいわ。
[音楽]
はい。しっかりとか守ってね。うーん。そうだ。
あのスイッチには応募条件があったわね。
時間以上プレイしないと応募できない。今壊せばプレイ時間は
0時間になる。
あ、お掃除。お掃除。あら、ごめんなさい。壊れちゃったわ。
[音楽]
おい、そういえばうちのルールはゲームは
1日1時間までだったわね。今からだと
時間は間に合わないからスイッチのお金はいらないわね。あんた子供なんだからこれで遊んでなさい。
[音楽]
くっそ、絶対許さねえ。俺はスイッチ2を
ゲットするためにある作戦を考えた。
[音楽]
これで準備は整った。
よし、直すぞ。できた。現在のプレイ時間は
[音楽]
時間だがぶっ続きであれば抽選応募にはギリ間に合う。そのためには。
う、な、何これ?お母さんいつもありがとう。き、気持ちが悪いわ。あ、で、でも我慢できない。だきます。
[音楽]
ごちそうさ。なんだか眠くなってきたわ。う、むにゃむにゃむにゃむにゃ。
当分の取り過ぎでお母さんは当分起きない。そして遠くにぶ当分だ。行け。
これで50時間プレイできるぜ。
その後俺は寝る時間を削ってぶっ続けるスイッチをやり続けた。
けけけけけ
[拍手]
[音楽]
行け行け行け行け行け行け
化け物が
どうしたの?みんな早く逃げろ。
え、
絶対に50しかやらせないわ。早く行け。
[音楽]
ここから離れろ。俺から離れろ。あ、
なんてな。そんなこともあろうかと先に手は打っておいた。
[音楽]
こうなったら行け行け行け行け行け行け。ほ
もちろん地面も特殊加過加工の床に張り替えて対策済みさ。
なめやがって。行け行け行け行け行け行け。残り
分耐えてくれ。行け行け行け行け行け行け行け。うわー。もう観念しなさい。
[音楽]
まだだ。スペアのスイッチを改造して作っ
たロボット。ロボッチ1号だ。
ぶっ壊しな。
ああ。
[音楽]
とどめだ。
[拍手]
頼む。ロボっち時間を稼いでくれ。
充電切れ。
ええ。うわあ。
残念でした。終わった。
大ただよ。
あ。ああ。
なんでな?お望み通り風船で遊んでおいたよ。メインのスイッチは風船で飛ばしておいて、今はダミのスイッチをやってたってわけ。応募条件の
[音楽]
時間クリアだ。応募条件クリアしたからスイッチ
買ってくれるよね。約束を守るのがうちのルールでしょ。
[音楽]
もう分かったわ。買ってあげるわ。はい、募了。
やった。い、
[音楽]
やねちゃん当選しました。
やった。
スイッチ2で遊るって伝えなきゃ。
えほ、えほ、えほ、えほ。
[音楽]
届いたんじゃない?これスイッチ
2じゃなくてスイッチ
2じゃねえか。
この動画の撮影中にあの
Hikakin
さんから謎のダンボールが届いたので開けてみたいと思います。
ということで撮影中になんとこんなボールが届いたんで皆さんで開けていきましょう。何かな、何かな?
せーのオープン。
おお、来た、来た、来た。さ、さ、さ。
はい。キすぎ。
せーのドン。誰?誰?誰?誰?
お。あ、2人いる。
前回もらったんですけど
1番使ってるから多分。YouTuber
で
キのラーメンができました。
ありがとう。
ということでニセキさんとニセキさんとこちらみ噌食べていきます。ただきます。
[音楽]
うまい。マジでうまい。え、
うまいね、これ。
めちゃめちゃ美味しかったです。ちょ、視聴者の皆さんも食べてください。そして
HIKAK
inさんいつかコラボ待ってます。
ありがとうございます。
はい、お願いします。
ちゃちゃちゃちゃちゃ登録。
チャンネル登録チャンネル登録よろしく登録よろしく最初はグチャンネル登録チャンネル登録まチャンネル登
[音楽]